I won the money on the Saturday and a
Sunday it was the solo sternum which I
didn't qualify for and my friend career
from Lazarus as well
he won 1 million so we all went out to
celebrate and went to this piece of
place and like kind of massive piece and
with all my friends and family that's
the way to do it and has it sunk in
about how much money you actually have
won
not really to be honest with you like
I'm still kind of like like wrapping it
around my head how much money I've won
but it truly make it easier unlike my
mom and all my family like it just be
easier and a lot less stress and
everything and tell me what's it like
competing knowing but I mean just in
that full stadium itself for knowing
millions of people are also watching all
around the world how does that compare
with I don't know playing at home
wherever you play in your bedroom or
whatever I mean it's a different kind of
pressure to be fair I had the pressure
really well like a lot better than I
expected
but it's the atmosphere like in a
stadium like if you made like a good
play like the crowd cheer and you could
hear it for your headset like we had
like noise cancelling headphones but the
crowd was so loud like you could just
hear everyone scream as soon as like
something will happen so like it really
like put a little bit more pressure on
me to perform but Rodo my older partner
he's like 21 and he's like a lot more
mature than me so he helped me get
through it and like he's had experience
before in like competitions you see we
did really well yeah you did you seem
pretty mature to me already Jade now
tell me next year is a massive year for
you isn't it because as you say you're
pretty confident you'll get in to this
work up again but GCSE year isn't it as
well what about the school work so yeah
I'm in there six weeks holiday now so
I've got a lot of time to just
capitalize on like my success right now
so I'm gonna be streaming on my twitch
and uploading on YouTube and everything
but my schooling I'm like doing pretty
well right
like I could be doing better like my
gaming's kind of got cut into my
schoolwork a little bit but I'm pretty
bright so I've been getting on with what
I've had to do okay but career-wise I
know it's a long way off do you you see
yourself first stayin in gaming you
think you can make well you've already
made a living out of it do you think you
can make even more money out of it yeah
yeah yeah definitely I'm I'm really like
focused on like my gaming so I'm
definitely gonna try and make a career
out of it like streaming and connect
prayin so I hopefully can make a decent
living out of it okay and that's caused
on the way here it's caused some
tensions hasn't it some arguments with
your mother throwing out an Xbox she
said breaking one of your headsets
yeah what's called me and my mother I'd
like a few tension between like my
gaming and stuff like she's been a bit
worried about their mouth hours I've
been planning on it thinking that like
I'm just sitting in my room wasting my
time and everything but I've kind of
like this has kind of proved to her that
I can actually make a living out of my
game in yeah he said he can and I just
tell me there was some tension about
getting there wasn't there as well is it
true the dog ate your birth certificate
as you were trying to get a visa so I
picked the wrong box on my ESEA so it's
like the Visa Waiver
yeah and cuz I thought that because I'm
earning money in the US I basically were
there for like a job but it wasn't so I
had to like say no in the box by ticked
yes so we had to go to the embassy we
was thinking about going to Brussels at
because there was a one-day wait in
Brussels to get a visa but there was a
30-day way in London where I'm from so
we was really scared that he wasn't
gonna be able to come so my mum booked a
an emergency appointment I was really
lucky to get it so my visa got approved
so and then my dad came over to give the
birth certificate and then we came
downstairs like yeah mum you've got
other stuff right so we went downstairs
and it's just in pieces all over the
floor coz my dogs just munched it all
the way up and I like like I was just I
was like what the hell is going on
they couldn't got any worse